hey guys weather is fantastic and i'm
going to go grab a bite to eat once this
is over and done with because there's
some good food up there too of course
one of the big things about this
celebration of life festival are the
wonderful art author altars i should say
that we celebrate for dia de los muertos
and this one behind me here is one
that's done by the nevada donor network
and this is a special one because
everyone you see here in those pictures
have not only passed but they've also
donated their organs to help others and
specifically this one on the bottom
named cameron we're going to bring in
his mother paula here to tell us a
little bit more about about cameron such
a wonderful kid yes he was he was
11 when he passed he was funny very
outgoing loved to help people that was
his biggest thing he loved to help he
loved helping everybody at his school
his friends
and he just loved everybody he was
definitely
a people person right and then of course
he he saved many lives donating his
organs correct right yes he saved three
lives he saved a four-year-old a
six-year-old and a 31 year old so
they're all doing good too so
thank you for cameron for that and and
how did he celebrate you got he was a
big fan of dia de los muertos when you
guys celebrated right yeah they used to
celebrate it in school so he would make
little sugar schools at school and bring
him home you know have a big tub full of
all kinds of stuff he would bring home
from school and then he loved the show
or the movie coco
he loved that so it's that movie is
awesome because it explains you know it
to children and
that stuff is kind of hard to explain to
kids so it was actually really cool so
well paul thank you so much and and god
bless you and your wonderful son cameron
and your husband as well thank you so
much as for all of that too and that's
part of the celebration all right it's
not about a day of mourning it's a day
of celebration the life that everyone
here had with their relatives and that's
part of dia de los puertos